[Musique]
ce
après il y a
[Musique]
c'est ma femme qui a réservé les billets
parce qu'on est au courant que
maintenant c'était réglementée et que
pour voilà préserver la nature il
fallait réguler le flux qui est vraiment
très intense l'été nous c'est une très
bonne chose
[Musique]
on a ouvert les places à la réservation
jeudi à 9h et l'ensemble des places
étaient partis autour de 16h les 400
places étaient réservées hier ou
avant-hier on a regardé sur le sur le
site s'était déjà plaint
[Musique]
il ya moins de monde donc c'est plus
marcher c'est plus cool pour être point
d admirer la nature la mer depuis moins
de deux mois c'est mieux
[Musique]